draft for today who or what are you
missing most by not being in
indianapolis this is the week we'd be in
indy we'd be leaving right now i know i
would be we do till friday and then we
get out of there uh so that's what we're
gonna do
for the draft and i have a question for
you to determine the first pick peter
where
was the first ever nfl combine held
phoenix
oh no i can't even say close to the
other side of the country tampa in 1982
tampa was the first uh combat and and
just just as an idea one of my favorite
combine story old school style just to
give a flavor for how far it's come
in 1980
when major harris the former west
virginia quarterback went to the
scouting combine he showed up for the
workouts
in blue jeans and a dress shirt
and he i he had street shoes not running
shoes so somebody had to supply him with
shoes so he could he could do the events
that's what it was like in 1989 and oh
how it is well i'll give you my can i
give you what it used to be like back in
the day the year 2000 holiday inn crown
plaza hotel
uh the combine is there the players are
there they're still there i mean they
would be there this year the exact same
place well that year there's about 15 or
20 reporters there
i spend an hour and a half over lunch
with plexigo burris and wrote a story
for sports illustrated the following
week based on my conversation with
plexigo burris for an hour and a half
okay now let's fast forward to last year
1243
credentials issued by the national
football league not 15 to 20
and for every player there you are
fortunate and i mean fortunate
to get a question walking with them
as they are walking off the podium and
being led somewhere by security
that's the difference in the scouting
combine
all right first pick for me and look
this is very basic very simple but it's
also very true and authentic the thing i
miss the most is constantly searching
for the cowboys bus
where is the cowboys bus it's the nfl's
equivalent of the oscar meyer wiener
wagon you're constant i know i am
constantly looking around in
indianapolis for that big giant white
bus with the blue star on the side i
miss that
i miss
running into
a general manager or coach
at 11 53 in the evening
a general manager or a coach who might
have had a couple beers too many
and might tell me something that he
would not have told me at 9 43 in the
morning
walking into the
doors of lucas oil stadium
that is what i miss
i i miss the feeling of
seeing someone
and
thinking i should know who it is but
when you get coaches off of a sideline
when you get general managers out of the
luxury suite where you see them during
their games and they're not wearing
their their colors and their gear
sometimes it takes a little while to
register who is that guy and i'll give
you an example a few years ago we had a
head coach on set with this and they're
doing the row of press conferences on
the other side of the room and there's a
guy at each podium
and the coach said to me who the hell is
that down at the left who is that guy it
was brett veach but nobody know who
nobody knew who brett vitre they know
now he's the guy who found patrick my
homes but that you know you see these
names you see not names you see these
faces and they're all jumbled together
and it's like wait a minute which guy is
that what team is he with and and i i
both miss that feeling and don't miss
that feeling because i feel like i go
through that every year peter
i miss my five breakfasts
slash
lunch
uh at this breakfast place in downtown
indianapolis
called patachew
and patachu is great because if you walk
in there
at
8 15 in the morning during the scouting
combine
you are going to see five people who you
know because you've seen them on
television
you know so
though i miss that because i would have
45 minutes with somebody at all times
uh you know and i would always i'd
always get there first
and i would get a table in the corner
you know why
because you want a table in the corner
with me
sitting with my face toward the room and
the person i'm going to have breakfast
with sitting with his back to the room
so he has fewer people coming up to him
and saying hey coach or hey you know
whoever and so
i missed that
but you kind of sound like the reason
why you know as an italian i like to sit
in the back of the restaurant with
everything in front of you you want to
make sure if you're going to get whacked
you want to see it coming so it's that's
the same but it's not the same last one
for me but this is similar to it i miss
the feeling of asking myself am i about
to get punched now not when it you know
the the normals but when you're out and
about and you know there's people out
there that you've shared some strong
opinions about there have been times
where i've just kind of had that
fleeting feeling of am i about to get
punched i both miss
and not miss that because it would be a
hell of a story if i did get punched but
i don't want to get punched
i miss
walking through the concourse at
the convention center
leading to and from
hotels
and lucas oil stadium
and just walking along and all of a
sudden you see somebody last year i saw
jordan palmer
okay and i talked to jordan palmer about
he's the kind of the quarterback mentor
and i talked to jordan palmer about his
guys and who he's got and he always
comes up with two or three tidbits for
me or walking along and all of a sudden
you see a trainer that you might know
and you might be able to ask him about a
rehabbing player which he can't talk
about on the record but because you know
him he might say
yeah it's it might be longer than we
thought
those are the things that you miss
because those are the people that
normally you would never see
yeah i i it's funny there's a there's a
huge difference between yours and mine
yours are more work related and actually
about mining information mine are about
the experience but uh
my last one is also about the experience
i miss pretending that the dinner spots
in indianapolis are actually good
uh that's i miss that
because don't we we do that every year i
mean really really
over i'm not gonna name names but
overrated is the word that comes to mind
for uh the the some of the places
especially the one that everyone talks
about and maybe they use that that
special sauce to burn out your taste
buds so you don't realize that the rest
of the meal isn't very good but mike
you know what i have learned over the
years going to indianapolis
don't just go here okay go here
and that's where a lot of the nfl people
are going now because
you go here you got this small little
circle but go through the concentric
circles
go to bluebeard next year that's where i
want you to go bluebeard
you're gonna love bluebeard it's a great
place
and there are a bunch of places like
that but
i think indianapolis i love indianapolis
i really love it you know why because
i go there for five days and i never get
in the car
i just walk in try this even the time
it's like a mile away but it's it's just
it is so great to be able to go there
and just to be able to say oh yeah
that's five blocks over here it's three
blocks over there i know they're going
to move the combine eventually to i'm
sure to la because they need events at
the new nfl campus there
i will miss
indianapolis as much as i miss anything
about the nfl because it is so
convenient and you see
everybody
it will be a huge mistake if they move
it and they just don't care they want to
make it a bigger event than it already
is and the only way they're going to
make it bigger is to take it from
indianapolis to l.a so next year i'll go
to bluebeard and while i'm looking out
the window to spot the cowboys bus
someone will punch me and it will all
come full circle
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports